[Music]
in the heart of woodbury connecticut
stands the state's oldest in
the curtis house
opened in 1736 the 16 bedroom inn has
been owned and run by the hardestly
family for nearly 60 years and is
currently being run by chris hardesty
and his sister tj the curtis house is
haunted
sea
the rooms will all be done and the
comforters will be nice and neat and
tidy and you can go back in five minutes
later and it looks like somebody rolled
across it i would walk by a table and
two minutes later a plate would fly off
of it i went to light the fireplace and
it blew up on me and i got burns
there are spirits here but spirits
aren't paying guests and the curtis
house bedrooms are empty most nights
right now i would say we're about a
hundred thousand dollars in debt
my dad recently passed away he had a
firm belief that my brother and i could
take over the end it just left me more
determined
to succeed
failing to continue their father's
success with the inn has destroyed chris
and tj's relationship they hardly ever
speak and when they do they fight for
mean horrible [ __ ] if we were married
we'd probably be divorced by now you
come off like this every time all the
time she's controlling she wants things
done her way because when i sit there
and give a rule i want the rule followed
my brother frustrates me to the point
where sometimes i would like to just
bop them over the head to get rid of
some frustrations another woman who
doesn't listen to the [ __ ] thing i
say
chris and tj's frustrations with each
other and their failing business have
made the inn hell for staff
no my tray no my tray i just i don't
give a [ __ ] they just don't care if you
look at your boss who doesn't care why
are you gonna care
tj's not a great leader she yells at you
i've never heard a thank you i think you
can go a long ways
chris he's just a fat lazy slob [ __ ]
everywhere we will get complaints from
the customers we will have problems with
dishes it's just shrugged off he doesn't
give a crap
i've lost respect for tj and christopher
we've lost a lot of customers because of
management
since tj and chris both took over
everything is going downhill
there's a stain on my tongue disgusting
look at this wow
close the bathroom door
like a rusted soap holder did you have
your tetanus shot
everything sucked give me another plate
without answering
i would never come here again
if things don't improve and fast a
family legacy could come to a tragic end
the curtis house is a huge thing to our
family we've been here for
59 years we've all pretty much grown up
here curtis house is like my second home
it has been all these years the same
with my mother and my aunts
if the curtis house shut down it would
really feel like we lost a part of our
family
i'm on my way to the curtis house it's
connecticut's oldest inn i'm excited
about it because it's supposed to be one
of new england's historical gems there's
nothing wrong with being the oldest
just depends how much botox you've had
i'm going to be arriving on a big day
for hotels and restaurants across
america but there's something i've got
to do first
hello hi mum
oh hi how are you i'm very well thank
you i'm just bringing you to wish you
happy mother's day
oh thank you so much gordon and your
flowers were lovely thank you very much
it's very kind of here well i'm sorry i
can't be with you thank you so much for
following us
have a great day love you lots love you
bye bye now
ah great here we are the curtis house
connecticut's oldest aim lovely
the happy mother's day sign looks a bit
crap but i suppose it's the thought that
counts
look at this place
built before 1736 incredible
hi there gordon nice to see you welcome
to the curtis house happy mother's day
thank you very much and what's your
first name babe i know you're a baby
what's your name shirley shirley nice to
see my dad so it's mother's day the
restaurant's booked today's big day
right yes is the hotel full
not tonight oh how many rooms are books
just one
just one yeah just me yes
so i'm a little bit early okay usually
checking is three o'clock
there's usually a ten dollar an hour fee
that's what four hours so 40 already yes
so i could save a little bit of money by
hanging out and actually going to the
room yes
so i want to save myself 40 bucks yes so
if i just take a little nap
what is he doing
mr ramsey
that's really not appropriate
mr ramsey
gordon
[Music]
this isn't very appropriate oh
i'm checking i'm sorry i'm joking but it
doesn't make sense you charge me ten
dollars an hour if i just hang out on
the sofa get a little blanket i can save
myself some money
you know this rule actually went into
effect about six months ago just ten
dollar an hour i really think and is it
making a big impact on the business
people don't like it the bookings in the
rooms have definitely gone downhill i
think they would be a lot busier if tj
didn't have these ridiculous rules
um is that right my details in here
credit card details yes we take a credit
card number to hold the room i
appreciate that but why put it in the
book that's the house policy and if the
customer insists then we can't erase it
once they check
i got the credit card details to
everybody i will have to call 9-1-1
i don't really have to call 9-1-1 do i
babe see by the time you've called 9-1-1
okay i've hacked into every
credit card in this book
and made myself a fortune so whose
policy is this a bit weird this is a
house policy um like tj likes him the
owner yes would you not think there's a
security breach there that's why her
policy is no one to look in this book
except the desk person well
okay
i can't believe you're going to be in
room 16. why because room 16 has a ghost
in it
this woman told me who went to room 16.
she said the ghost was pulling the
blankets off her all night long and you
haven't been drinking cherry
wow betty is a ghost at the curtis house
and people do tell us that she raises a
little bit of havoc with them she's
definitely there
i'm 16.
a haunted dream
my goodness me
what is that on there
that footprint
come on no way so what's all that big
scuffy yes it looks like a footprint to
me
and what's that in there
dead bugs
oh dear oh geez look at this one here
i'll give them a list of the rooms that
are coming in they're supposed to
thoroughly check the room and what
do we do we have electricity in the
house
i couldn't believe what gordon found in
that room and what is this
nobody just realized her care
how long have you been working here i've
been on since about 1965. how was it
then busy all the time 48 years that's
incredible so this place means a lot to
you oh yes my second home are you
connected to the family in any way tj's
parents and my mother were cousins
so it must
be sad for you to see it struggling yes
definitely and why is it struggling
that's the way our two bosses get along
and was it different when tj and chris's
parents were running it oh yeah much
more professional so why do you stay why
did you put it with us i take pride in
this place i like this place i can see
that i really do but they don't
understand that the place is really
worth it
i really think tj and chris are really
hurting the business
somebody needs to knock some sense into
them first impressions um dismal all my
credit card details downstairs in that
book in such a vulnerable position one
of the busiest weekends ever for this
hotel with mother's day i'm the only one
staying in the hotel that's that's not
good
dust everywhere a windowsill full of
bugs i don't think i'm gonna get
possessed staying here i think i'm gonna
get a disease
right go downstairs have a look
babe let me out
honestly
it must be the bloody ghost come on
betty let me out i just want to get some
lunch i've just arrived at the curtis
house in woodbury connecticut and
they've given me a room with a ghost and
a door lock that doesn't work at last
i'm the only guest in this hotel despite
the fact it's mother's day and the
restaurant is fully booked hey what a
dreadful missed
opportunity hello good afternoon how are
you
i'm doing welcome how about you this is
hi my name is tj tj nice to meet you
yes nice to see you nice to see you this
is my mother happy mother's day thank
you very much uh it's an absolute honor
to meet you are you working today i have
worked every holiday and never got paid
ridiculous you should be sat having
lunch
enjoy this business um should we go to
the table we shall
time for me to see if the hotel's
restaurant is as bad as the bedrooms
right
hi my name's karen i'll be taking care
of you are you connected to the family
yes i am i'm tj and uncle chris's niece
okay nice
and just in a nutshell um what's wrong
with the place
now there's no communication between my
aunt and uncle it's gotten a million
times worse since my grandfather passed
away
doesn't it yeah i asked brother to come
here because my family desperately needs
his help they've been struggling for way
too long they don't know what to do we
really need his help this is the dinner
menu
wow
what would you say crab cakes the crab
cakes
yeah you yes oh don't look at me like
that slight hesitation they're they're
hit or messed up they're hell messed
yeah uh cupcakes uh what else um i'll
take some calamari okay um johannes have
a little tasty logo how do you like it
cookies medium rare medium rare you're
welcome
okay mike
all right listen this is ramsay crab
cakes
calamari with gorgonzola when he wants
the burger medium rare i am very proud
of my food whenever i eat other places i
think we're better than 90 of them do we
have calamari in the line or no
the crab cakes lovely
um let's do this together would you mind
please
come on you're supposed to be my wingman
i i had to swallow it was not enjoyable
hit or miss for me that's a miss yeah
holy [ __ ] bees i warned you about me
about you thank you you're welcome
how was lunch my darling it wasn't very
good everything feels institutional
right you know like we just got out of
the hospital and it's the best food we
could get i'm sorry it's not a nice
surprise for mother's day no it's not
calamari and then i'll have the pork the
burger hey cocktail sauce pork and lemon
monkey dish for the marinara
so fried calamari
can you hear any christmas
that's limper than my granddad's dick
oh my god oh my god oh my god
that's disgusting it's awful it's
awful
yeah okay thank you you're welcome
yes what we're doing the calamari was
mostly greasy you know i have to bring
this food out you know he's gonna
critique it and you know i'm gonna come
right back with it in one second because
you don't care you're just sending me
like
[ __ ] on a plate basically
any mushrooms mike
ah
my burger your burger thank you very
much jesus where's my burger
a mess
did you tell him it's medium rare
jesus it's raw that is not medium rare
what a shame
that is dreadful my uncle can't cook a
burger medium rare are you freaking
kidding me can you tell me i need to use
mrs chef of course yeah thank you oh
you're uncool yeah i'm cool oh chris i
can't believe how bad my food was i've
got to see the kitchen in action for
myself right back here is my cousin mike
hi
[Applause]
uncle chris okay so tj's little brother
yes brother mike trudeau my show good to
see you
this is cheyenne giant
fire you have a mushroom wrap one all
day and a primavera planet
[Applause]
10 minutes i'm amazed none of you asked
me how lunch was
what's most shocking isn't the food or
that they have zero interest in my
experience as a diner it's the fact that
chris and his sister don't exchange a
single word they won't even look at each
other
you could cut the atmosphere in here
with a knife
wow this guy must really hate mothers
the way he's treating these dishes you
put food on a plate like you're stopping
it can i borrow that cloth a minute
you're wiping plates with this
you don't care
i don't know about that
to
say that not know me at all doesn't have
any foundation
jesus christ
is anything cooked to order here
french rice salads
french fries salad [ __ ]
20 [ __ ] dollars i had for that
chris doesn't seem like an owner or a
chef he isn't even cooking he's just
heating things up chris you got two
seconds please
here's where i'm getting frustrated you
own the place you cook like you hate the
place
come on chris talk to me please
if you're not going to talk to me then
i'm wasting my time here
what's the point curtis house in
woodbury connecticut is falling apart
because owners chris and tj won't talk
to each other and it's affecting the
inn's guests as well as the food that is
dreadful i don't know if they'll ghost
upstairs but there's definitely a dead
man walking in the kitchen
you own the place you cook like you hate
the place
this place is a mess it's like nobody
cares here one thing's for sure it is
not happy [ __ ] families let me tell
you
all right ghost stories and legends of
southwestern connecticut wow
room 16 is host to doting female paying
special attention
to male guests staying in the room she
tucks them into the bed
and may even crawl
next to them what
at least they've got one regular guest
betty
it's you
okay
i didn't get a visit from betty the
ghost but i still had a rough night's
sleep wow i feel so dusty after last
night
i don't bet he's not watching from that
[ __ ]
man
this inn has been in the harassing
family for four generations and i can't
understand why tj and chris have no
appreciation for what has been given to
them
i've called a staff meeting and i'm
hoping this will get them talking before
they lose their family heirloom just
wanna have a quick chat with you all
my first impressions have not been good
but i struggle to believe that you two
are brother and sister
it is shocking
no communication not even looking at
each other
why can't you two
at least
talk to each other get frustrated with
some things and all the time we talk and
talk about doing [ __ ] and we never get
anything done and you think this is what
your father wanted no it's absolutely
not
what's wrong with this place i feel like
it's management
you know thank you would be nice every
once in a while you know that's all i
ask for i'm more hurt than angry because
i care so much about them you sound like
you push the breaking point yeah i felt
like tj and christopher don't give a
[ __ ] i don't know how much more i can
take try when did the drive go out of
the kitchen when did the essence when
did the word passion disappear i've
never seen all three in that kitchen
ever ever i feel like i am the voice of
truth everybody else either one doesn't
care or two they just don't see it i've
been saying since day one that this
kitchen is a joke there are no standards
in the kitchen chef
it's depressing [ __ ] cheyenne his
opinion doesn't really matter to me
never has never will
i watched you in the kitchen it was like
you were just hired as an extra
and tj your feud with your brother is
clearly getting in the way of running
your business the staff are desperate
and you know what hurts
it's a blessing that you've got this
place the potential is huge
yet you walk around and treat it like
it's a curse
i came to your inn as a guest and i am
not [ __ ] happy
both of you are asleep walking to
disaster
go to your office and at least try to
talk
if you can't talk you might as well
close the doors right now
you know in the 30 years i've been here
i never had anybody ever complaint like
that and it makes it tough and then
throw it in my face even harder you know
hi
okay
no what's wrong you really
gave me a wake-up call
because this place is toxic tj has
issues i think she's a control freak and
you talking to them they're standing
there as far as i'm concerned they made
asses out of themselves
i'm done here
i cannot work here no more this is your
life this is your yeah and it's
destroying i can see that
they don't care about us
they need to hear it from you
okay
i can't believe it's come to this as far
as i'm concerned tj and christopher
they're not gonna change it's a total
shame
hey
how are you
not good
[Music]
i i i can't
i can't work here anymore i'm sorry it's
destroying me
i don't like it
you know i care about every one of my
staff here you don't you make people
feel uncomfortable and i'm telling you i
don't know whether anybody else is going
to speak up
i'm not saying that i'm perfect by any
means at all either but you know i don't
think that there should be personal
attacks this is the way i feel whether
you guys like it or not because it's
just killing me i feel as though there's
no future i'm done
you're giving me a look like every
single bit of that is justified a lot of
the [ __ ] she says is true tj nobody
wants to [ __ ] talk to you i am not
going to have her tell me that i'm this
mean horrible monster that doesn't give
a [ __ ] everybody mean horrible [ __ ]
everybody i really think you need to
[ __ ] talk to somebody or do something
before you're in a padded [ __ ] room
i disagree the proof is in the pudding
you're strung out you're [ __ ] tweaked
right to the [ __ ] end every day
because you don't have any help and then
you turn into a miserable [ __ ] cycle
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up she didn't know
what she was [ __ ] talking about
the broken relationship between the
owners of connecticut's curtis house inn
has gotten to an all-time low
everybody thinks you're a mean horrible
[ __ ] i asked them to talk for the first
time in months but all they did was yell
at each other shut the [ __ ] up
i'll keep this brief i've got to get
them to see if they don't communicate
this in or shut its doors
i don't know what it's going to take to
wake you up you've already lost one of
your employees because you can't get it
together you're starting to resent each
other
and the work you're doing oh i i agree
but i think it's hard to come to work
knowing the minute you walk in the door
until you walk out the back door there's
a disagreement in every room you're in
it used to be that we talked things
through we just stopped doing it just
been frustrated
frustrated every [ __ ] day for three
years yeah you know if you got so
frustrated with me three years ago that
you just stopped talking it's
horrible
every [ __ ] time we talked would turn
into an argument and
i was just avoiding the arguments
you know just got [ __ ] fed up
we're not talking three months
three years
when was the last time either of you
stayed here and see how the guests
experienced it through their eyes you've
never done it
it shows
can both you come with me please there's
something in my room i'd like to show
you
if chris and tj won't listen to each
other maybe they'll listen to the people
who could keep their business alive
please
both you take a stand over there
here we have some guests and i think
you're gonna find their feedback
invaluable
let's start off with you first just
pulling back the comforter honestly it
looked like the sheets hadn't been
changed and the chair kind of picked up
the cushion and there was
for lack of a better word a skid mark on
the bottom of the cushion it was
disgusting
uh the pillows had some stains on them
insects on the windowsills it looks like
the windows haven't been washed in a
while we had the flowers like in here
they had like an inch of dust on them we
did not have a bathroom door we had a
wicker like divider and when you tried
to pull it it just kind of falls over
wow
jump in guys i mean you know these are
customers are paying money it's very
disheartening i've never got responses
like this before and
i i wish i had
can i talk to you about the arrival when
you arrive you hand over your personal
credit card details addresses
your cell numbers
what do you think happens to your
details after you've left
because in this book
is all of your credit card details
oh here we go this is it this is the
hammer
it is vital information of your credit
card details your addresses your cell
numbers
in
black and white
this is a
ticking time bomb
how does that make you feel with
everything that's going on nowadays with
the identity theft and everything like
that i'm not police at all about that
would you be so kind just to leave me
here with the owners for two minutes
please i appreciate your feedback thank
you guys
jesus
[Music]
you asked me here to come and help you
but you both need to change your ways
you won't open up to me and you won't
open up to each other your business is
literally dying because you won't
communicate but it's like you don't care
i can't even start to move forward
because i'm not feeling the [ __ ] the
hunger
that both of you want this place to work
so i'm just saying [ __ ] it sell it
[Music]
i'm gonna stairs
not again
oh my gosh gordon can't even find the
solution
takes two
takes two hands to get out
i love this place i love this place with
all my heart but the way things are
going
the revelation is is just not worth it
i'm really struggling to get through to
chris and tj the person who knows them
better than anyone is their mother trudy
and i'm hoping she may help me to unlock
that divide between them and hopefully
get these two back on track
[Music]
i mean i came to see this morning
because i need your help
i'm struggling to get through to tj and
i'm struggling to get through to
chris
they don't communicate they don't drive
the business forward they just bicker
and butt heads why is that
i don't know
i don't know why
how much does that inn mean to you i
mean what does it stand for in your
family
it stands for the homework it's nothing
else yeah
we all had to work in there
you should be reaping the rewards of the
family success in nearly six decades
but how would it make you feel this
business was sold to different family
now i mean
all that work of you and your husband's
commitment
i don't want another bitter change yeah
i really don't want to see it go down
the street tomorrow
i want to see if those two can't come
back together and get it back on their
feet
i really want to help your family and i
really want to keep this business alive
for another 60 years so we're gonna have
to get them to talk to each other
otherwise the business is doomed
well
you're right
and i need your help
please
you got it
thank you i'll see you back at the end
okay okay thank you my life
coming up
the two of you to be able to communicate
as brother and sister is more important
than
even the sin has changed come too late
for the curtis house
the curtis house in woodbury connecticut
is sinking
because the two owners won't speak to
each other and despite the hotel's dire
situation i've been unable to get
through to chris and tj come on chris
you don't care
so i went to see their mum and i need
your help you got it now trudy has
organized a family intervention to let
tj and chris know how much they're
fighting is hurting the inn and everyone
around them hi guys
first of all uh to you guys i appreciate
you being here
your mum has brought everyone together
just to talk to you from the bottom of
their heart
i hope this is gonna open your eyes
because right now i don't know what will
who died to go first
tess
what have you got to say my darling
mom i think that you're spread way too
thin
we think that the mounting work is
getting to be too much you're getting
frustrated and eventually it's bound to
spill over but i think that
for the two of you to still be able to
talk and communicate as brother and
sister is more important than
even the sin
currently
i've sat with both of you
many times
talked about all the problems you guys
just go back and forth
there's no resolve nothing you have to
get on the same page about it it's
way too much for everyone in this place
it's awful
something has to change
thank you don
hey honey okay tj and chris i really
hope we can all get through this
this is so important you've been here
for 48 years you know this place better
than anybody
the two of you were so close to so many
years i know because i was there and
i've seen it
we used to come to work and do a job and
really enjoy working with each other
and with both your stubbornness you took
that all away
since you two stop speaking everything
is going downhill
i want to help you two get back together
like it used to be
and i know the curtis house can be that
way again and only you two can make that
happen
we all want to be there for you and help
you
and with a lot of hope and help from
gordon's expertise we can get
connecticut's oldest and curtis house
back to where it should be
and you two then can be very very proud
of what you accomplished
truly my darling
can these two make it work
they sure can
sure can they have
and we're behind the monitor
they are desperate
beyond belief
to help you make this place work
[Music]
you both have to step up
[Music]
when he walks through the door i have to
be the person that's there for him
that's it
but
i want to i want him to be my guy here
and i want to be the person he goes to
chris do you want
to make this work
[Music]
chris and tj's family have come together
for a last-ditch attempt to save the
curtis house inn by getting them to talk
to each other again now chris has to
decide if he'll commit to the inn or
walk away chris do you want to make this
work
absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
it just sucks that we've gone this far
got to stop being a jerk especially to
my sister
well right now i really just want to
make my mother proud of my family proud
it's been a family establishment all
these years and i have to make them
proud again
christopher and i let everything else
get in the middle of our relationship we
have to be each other's number one you
know family first we can do it
family united makes a stronger front you
ready yes absolutely
that was the first time we've seen that
in three years
it was like we did it
with chris and tj ready for change my
design team has worked all night to
transform the inn
[Music]
and now it's time to reveal the new look
to the team welcome to the new curtis
house connecticut's oldest
in run by an extraordinary family
providing a warm and welcoming
experience for other families
excited i can't wait you're gonna love
it are you ready to go inside yes we are
let's go follow me please
please come in
oh my god look at this
wow
oh my god that is awesome welcome to
your amazing new lobby
come through ladies
a decluttered
very welcoming warm space
over here we have
this stunning silhouette they are
historical portraits
of all your family
tj
come here come over here you okay
yeah the silhouettes of the family and
the staff it put me over the edge
because this business was built on that
you need to celebrate your family
history not be trapped by it
now one thing that concerned me on my
first arrival was the check-in
and that
reservation book that was gathering all
that sensitive personal data
come over please
oh my god what is that oh my god a
computer
now we know they didn't have these in
1754 but you can okay
the credit cards and all the personal
details will be safe we've had that red
book for years i'm so happy it's gone if
on tj brings the red book back out i
will burn it i'll do anything to make
sure we never see that thing again i'd
like to take you upstairs now uh to my
room you ready
you'll be pleased to know we've repaired
the door handle so it actually works how
come oh my god
[Music]
come on
have a look
wow
again steven's history but encapsulating
that modern elegance the panels on the
wall elevate the scope the depth of the
room tj
betty the ghost has her own cushion
i think betty's going to be very happy
with what gordon did i think she's going
to love the fact that she's become an
elegant feature so babe i want you to
come here please
stand there
don't relax turn around
and we look at the eyes of that picture
and move your head from left to right
and the eyes move the eyes follow around
the loom
oh my god the eye portrait it was really
creepy but
i would try to stay in there i might
have another room on backup just in case
i couldn't make it through the night but
i would definitely give it a try
ready to see another one
this one you gotta love it's my favorite
one let's go
oh my god
how beautiful what's that
oh my god it's gorgeous i really feel
the changes are going to help tj and i
get some things back into focus
my father would definitely like a lot of
the the changes i wish she was here to
see it
now you won't believe what i have
downstairs for you let's go
coming up i give babe a surprise she'll
never forget give that a french kiss
i've just shown the family their new
lobby
and the new bedrooms oh my gosh
now it's time to show them the new
improvements to the hotel restaurant
the inn has been in the hardesty family
for four generations wow wow so i've
come up with a new menu that reflects
the family's history
the curtis house family favorites oh my
god
we start off with grandma trudy's crab
cake i hit every single time tj's
grilled salmon and corn johnny cakes
chris's country fried pork chop dipped
in buttermilk so with mac and cheese
gravy and green beans you're only
allowed once a week man
and when you're cooking your family's
food there's gonna be so much more love
so much more care to what you're serving
now tuck in and enjoy
[Music]
oh that sauce is unbelievable
i'm really excited to show off the new
menu this is a good one
finally now this is something i can tell
people it's really really good
everything here is delicious very very
very good
it's like a new ball game
right whole new ball game
just like us
tonight is the relaunch of the new
improved curtis house as the guests
arrive there's a new sense of warmth and
welcome from tj and the staff
welcome to the curtis house how are you
i love the new work and i can't wait for
our customers to come in because i want
to see their reaction
we've got our own little fireplace i
love how it has that nice cozy cottage
feel but yet it moderates this is
definitely going to get people in the
rooms and be proud to send them up there
welcome to the curtis house thank you
let me take you upstairs to your room
down in the restaurant chris is taking
charge and putting in the care he needs
to make his diners happy
crab cakes need to go in the oven please
it feels very good to have the harvest
your name on a menu you know it's where
it should be definitely giving me a
little more focus a little more
direction and a little more immediate
pride yeah and use the spring for them
please thank you minecraft we're good
we're good
more importantly tj and chris are
working together and communicating is
that gone yes and then we got a clam and
a slider coming yes i think my brothers
and my attitude has changed dramatically
plating my clams right now waiting now
thank you
my brother and i our back's working very
well together how're we doing jordy
we're doing fine i'm getting all kinds
of compliments
oh baby you're all right ma you're all
right definitely one of the most
important things to me is to see my
mother and my sister and my family happy
tj and chris are finally working
together but i have one last thing i
need to do to help turn this business
around you must be donna good to see you
thank you
i've asked the paranormal expert to
investigate the spirits haunting the end
somebody here
[Music]
camera's acting really funky
[Music]
[Laughter]
you are officially
a member of the haunted connecticut
tours
and you are now officially haunted
congratulations thank you thank you very
much hang out with pride now that the
curtis house is certified as haunted and
on the ghost tour it will attract even
more business and help this family get
out of
debt all right ladies
i'm gonna say goodbye
we're not ready for you to leave no you
just can't leave i know my job is done
you two have been amazing if they stop
talking to each other call me please i'm
gonna miss you oh no come on babe i'm
gonna miss you two
little kiss
and
one two do you know they give you four
in paris
give that a french kiss
did give me two kisses on my cheek
yes i haven't washed it yet
[Music]
okay my time is done i'm gonna leave you
appreciate it thank you very much don't
let 60 years of hard work
disappear absolutely not promise me
you're going to continue talking to your
sister the minute you don't
the place is doomed
and you have a beautiful beautiful in
here thank you very much i can't wait to
come back
take care of them
look after each other please thank you
gordon ramsay put some life back into us
good night betty
gordon showed us where our relationship
should be and will be from this point on
i'm forever grateful to gordon ramsay
for coming in here and straightening us
out
i ain't afraid of ghosts
[Music]
since my visit tj and chris have learned
how important it is to work together pot
roasted chicken mashed only turkey as it
comes gordon pulled off something that i
wasn't sure was going to be able to be
mended i think i got my best friend back
and he's not going anywhere this time
there you go there's definitely
experience it's not a daily grind now
bookings for the hotel are up
if there's any spirits present in this
room and it's bringing in tourists who
want to get a glimpse of betty the ghost
good evening welcome to the curtis house
if gordon didn't come i think we were
pretty much done
you saved my family and just feels like
you gave us our life back
you